this giant brick facade has just about
survived the earthquake the frescoes
destroyed the nave left in ruins the
mirin dollar Cathedral has become a
symbol for the destruction caused by the
earthquake that struck the Amelia
regions last year only firemen are
allowed to enter the building they're
working to make it safe as parts of it
could crumble at any moment but it's a
race against time the priest is certain
that the cathedral won't survive another
winter dog this is our history our
identity the Cathedral has to be rebuilt
quickly it's just as important as
working and earning money our roots are
buried here llano student atop the
lesser annoys this treasured works of
art also lie under the rubble rescued
paintings and statues are being
carefully restored in a laboratory in
Modena but it's too late for some like
this statue of Madonna and her child
laid out as if on an operating table
there's only so much restorers can do
requesting liquid 17 hace pasar una casa
you can't eradicate the effects of an
earthquake like this the consequences
remain with the historical buildings the
art and the people to say something la
novela paparazzi now we have to look
ahead with courage Maddie and the hay
one today Massimo Nicoletti is trying to
do just that the first big earthquake
hit here in finale Amelia on May
twentieth of last year the rubble and
debris have been cleared away but there
are still traces of destruction this
house is being held together with bands
barbers Filippo very multi-parameter son
of a finale amelia is a ghost town no
one is interested in renting or buying
in the area gree is already done laconic
on the water so okay the government is
to blame the only dispense
money gradually are for fear that it
will fall into the wrong hands but it
takes too long and we don't have time
this area will die out really pretty
look at there in degree was about your
auntie Massimo nicoletti takes us to the
industrial zone the area is getting back
up and running but the companies have to
foot the bill for the rebuilding
themselves no one here had taken out
insurance against earthquake damage it
was an entirely unexpected event
Margaret took that no one in the
community the province or the region
told us about new building regulations
before the earthquake but they were
always concerned with everything else
from hygiene to sound protection allows
the pickle it caused it but a dependent
because he the manufacture of
transmission parts had to invest six
hundred thousand euros into his factory
for repairs and safeguarding the beans
are made from steel and concrete and
should hold up against another
earthquake if only the factory in
neighboring medulla had done the same
for workers died here under the rubble
the incident led to prosecution since
the stricter Building Regulations had
been in place in this area for five
years Nepal Valley is now an official
earthquake zone but only on paper Romano
kumasi believes that officials and
politicians underestimate the risks of
earthquakes in Italy crystal born in
DeBary mean savvy seamen we're still in
danger we have to investigate
residential buildings and factories in
terms of earthquake safety because a
powerful earthquake like the one we had
a year ago could hit northern Italy
again at any time as with having the
possibility Lucas is marooned with
devastating results for the economy
aundrea bombarda produces balsamic
vinegar and has had to tear down one of
his factories it was built according to
the old building regulations and its
demise lost bombarda millions
subito dopo terremoto numerous studies
turned up after the earthquake talking
about the tectonic fault line and the
tension in the earth below us the quest
of those it's been known about since the
80s without anything being done we were
all done either someone was asleep or
they kept very quiet it's nothing that
was popular think that is the warehouse
managed to withstand the quake the roof
in the vinegar barrels were made of wood
which was able to absorb the shock but
that was not the case of this church in
finale Amelia where Massimo nicoletti
married he can't believe that one year
after the quake so much still lies in
ruins